[Applause]
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive
uncle Joey here Wednesday what is it
February 22nd or some [__]
the sun's out the rain is gone the
[__] dam broke who gives a [__] uncle
Joey's here direct and in [__] person
you understand me
Wednesday smoking dope getting ready for
the church tonight seven o'clock
tomorrow night Minneapolis eight o'clock
but besides that let's talk about the
situation at hand
[__] Wednesday okay today's the
day you wake up you little huh it's
Wednesday hey it's hump day who gives a
[__] let them think it's hump day you
come out of the [__] cannon like a
[__] missile you understand me that
walk-around it's hump day [__] you every
day you gotta come out swinging dick and
give it our [__] advice you
understand me what do we smoke a
perennial from perennials I'm gonna make
myself ten o'clock I'm gonna go over
there pick up them shipment for the week
and I'm gonna continue this [__]
party understand me everybody but
worried about this everybody's worried
about that just worry about yourself
don't worry about not just worry about
your [__] self today okay
everything that's gonna happen is gonna
happen with or without your decision
meanwhile you're there with your head
stuck thinking about it who gives you
[__] there's a whole [__] is this
boxes envelopes laying around and you're
worried about who's president who's not
president gives a [__] picked it up and
put in your pocket [__] let them worry
about that [__] you know you got to
worry about you and how you gonna get
over today and how your days gonna be
[__] phenomena of not you crack
yourself thinking about this or that oh
my god the executive order who gives a
[__] you know what my see executive
waters in my world meet that's all that
[__] matters you do your own [__]
executive order and don't worry about
what this [__] up ahead or his
assistant or the rest of these [__]
Gentiles are doing well let's get the
[__] smoke in here cuz it's Wednesday
two quarter to 9:00 in the morning and I
got a whole [__] dad and that guy
jujitsu I got meetings
I got [__] podcasts I gotta go talk
to people you know and never
we've never [__] hands but you know
what we keep it together that's it
everybody's wait huh I'm so stressed out
with [__] stress what are you talking
about you take a breath you look them in
the eye you say hey suck my dick this is
my world [__]
oh look at that [__] smoke comes out
of your lungs the rest of the [__]
comes up and your passion starts to get
clearly understand me your path to get
you where you need to go today to make
sure these [__] can't stop you
cuz when I wake up in the mommy Taysom
they have to shoot me with a [__]
with a missile will stop uncle Joey the
heart and the balls it's all in 7:24 I
don't give a [__] I don't give a [__]
understand me
and that's your attitude you don't give
a [__] you're doing what you need to do
today to get you to where you need to be
that's it right your goals do you push
up your protein shake be good to
somebody make somebody's [__] things
don't they look good they smell good
whatever the [__] it is because when
you're saying that for somebody you're
making yourself feel better it's
positive affirmations they call whatever
the [__] they call that's why it's
always a beautiful day to be alive I
don't give a [__] if skunks are falling
out of the sky it's a beautiful day to
be alive I'm saying it's movin on the
ball here get this day cookin I got some
cough medicine for tonight you know ass
dog always [__] cutting edge of
edibles and [__] acid whatever the [__]
you got we're down you understand me
how did you do today they do a little
seminar whatever 12 you don't meet dog
I'm always up doing something you gotta
keep doing some you gotta keep moving
like a [__] shark if not they catch
you
that'll keep moving I'm saying if not if
you stop moving then you'll stop feeling
the [__] breathe you got to keep
moving
well you watch TV go to gym there's no
TV in your world you gotta keep writing
you gotta keep getting out there until
what you want isn't the palm of your
[__] hands that's the whole goal of
this thing it's what you want every day
you write what you want from your life I
want to do this I want every moon
I already brought my goals today what I
wants to tell you I wanna be a good
husband I want to be the friend I wanna
[__] take three shits write it down
and at the end of the day check them off
and watch how they all fall into place
but the power of the pen is the most
important [__] thing in the world you
don't believe me don't [__] believe
I got myself out of a mental prison with
the power pen if I could do and I'm a
[__] idiot
can you imagine when you could do you
that nice family you're smart you
graduated high school all that [__] so
just pick up a [__] [__] can you
imagine what you could do
you're a [__] sandwich grab your
balls pop those [__] cuz you're
going deep today body and I salute the
flag and tell them wanna suck your dick
is at the end of the day it's you and
that [__] casket laying there with a
suit no shoes on the [__] ball it's
your world [__] and that's it and
that's that one more ball and I gotta go
do things and my daughter is watching PJ
masks I gotta get into school I got
radio at 9:30 for Minneapolis don't
forget tomorrow night 8 o'clock we
[__] around
I'm gonna head drill blast I got all
[__] shipment delayed so hopefully
you'll be just as busy hopefully you'll
have a great day and hopefully you'll
shove your balls down somebody's [__]
mouth and tell them I'm running this
[__] uncle Joey here I love you
to all my heart and will not forget the
church tonight 7 o'clock and Minneapolis
I'm coming in heavy I got this [__] to
kill Prince you understand
I love your [__] have a great
day keep your eyes open and stay black
and make somebody's day love you